today the matt welsh show the left and
blm continue to be outraged over a cop
who saved a black woman from being
stabbed to death
they say the cop had no right to shoot
someone just because they were trying to
stab another person
this is yet another example of the
left's total rejection
of personal responsibility so today i
want to talk about that i want to talk
about personal responsibility as it
relates to
these police shootings also five
headlines including the white house
releasing one of the most repugnant and
irresponsible public statements
we've ever heard from the white house
and i don't think that's an exaggeration
speaking of repugnant
and irresponsible lebron james doxes the
cop in the micaiah bryant shooting also
a female athlete sues after she was
benched and
forced off her soccer team when she
refused to take a knee in solidarity
with blm
and our daily cancellation and so much
more today on the matt wall show
[Music]
[Applause]
well as the outrage of protests over the
shooting of mikaya bryan in columbus
ohio reaches
its third day now we've come to a point
that few were probably expecting
many on the left including quite
prominent people on the left which we'll
talk about
later on have decided that although we
still should not have the right to bear
arms
we should and do have the right to stab
each other with large
kitchen knives or at least some of us
have that right
it's now clear of course and was clear
from the moment the body cam footage was
released that mikaya bryant
though she was only 16 years old
sadly brought her death on herself by
attempting to
stab another person and doing it right
in front of a police officer
that's one of the best ways to get
yourself shot by a cop is to try to kill
someone
in front of a cop um and that copper to
ride arrived on the scene
because of reports that somebody was
trying to stab people
the shooting was not it's not only
justified but it's a it's a textbook
justified shooting this should literally
be
in textbooks at the police academy to
show what a justified shooting looks
like
yet as we've discussed the left at
really asks only two things
there's only two things they care about
when anytime somebody dies what they
want to know is
was it a cop who killed that person and
was the person black if the answer is
yes on both counts then by hook or crook
or butcher knife
they'll find a way to condemn the
officer as not only a murderer but a
racist
murderer and this time it has led them
to claiming
that knife fights quote unquote are just
a normal part of growing up this is a
normal thing a bit of childish mischief
you know your mom would yell out to when
you're out in the backyard hey you guys
aren't having another night fight are
you
knock off with those hijinks that's none
of that we don't do any knife fights
who among us has not tried to stab
someone else in the gut with a large
blade
they ask let he who has never attempted
to stab someone
cast the first stone and they're
surprised when
millions of stones rain down on them
because most of us have never tried to
do that
so two examples of this um talking point
should suffice
i think and there was a lot of this
yesterday but let's just go with two
examples
valerie jarrett and obama lackey tweeted
this yesterday she said
a black teenage girl named mikaya bryant
was killed because a police officer
immediately decided to shoot her
multiple times
in order to break up a knife fight
demand accountability
fight for justice hashtag black lives
matter
activist bree newsome had this to say
she said teenagers have been fighting
have been um have been having fights
including
fights involving knives for wait let me
back up teenagers have been having
fights
including fights involving knives for
eons
we do not need police to address these
situations by showing up to the scene
and using a weapon against one of these
teenagers
okay the first problem here the first
problem here is that it's completely
bonkers
uh the second is that this was not a
knife fight
i don't mean to get all technical but
this was a person with a knife
trying to stab somebody who didn't have
a knife so that's not a knife fight
that's what we generally in the business
we'll call
attempted murder right the third problem
is that
knife fights are not normal teenage
activities unless you're living
in in the west side story this is not a
normal part of growing up
now i could say i grew up in a school
system where fights
were unfortunately common but i never
saw anyone
get stabbed i've never even seen someone
wheel the knife
in anger in my entire life um the
you know the only i i cut myself once
accidentally
while trying to whittle an arrow with a
with a out of a tree branch
long story don't ask that's all of the
knife related carnage that i
personally have ever witnessed maybe
i've lived a sheltered life i don't know
maybe kids are out there dueling it out
with sharpened blades on a regular basis
you know i played kickball as a kid
dodgeball
tag pickup basketball it never occurred
to me to to
to uh add a stabbing element to any of
these games
but again maybe that's just me and if
leftists grew up
in an environment where kids were
constantly stabbing each other
i find that hard to believe but it would
also explain a lot
but this is the absurdity the left
reduces itself to
and the reason aside from the racial
narrative
uh which they're trying to establish and
the anti-police anti-law and order
narrative all of which we've talked
about many times and we'll continue to
talk about
but underneath all of that is a
rejection
of uh personal responsibility
it's funny because they say
accountability
valerie jarrett said we need
accountability that's exactly what you
don't want
because what they're really saying is
that it's not mikaya bryant's fault
that she was trying to stab someone
it wasn't dante wright's fault that he
was committing armed rob that he
committed armed robbery and then
was there was a warrant for his arrest
and then he resisted arrest that got
shot in the process
it wasn't jacob blake's fault it wasn't
george floyd's honor no no it's none of
their phones
the fault cannot rest with any of those
individuals
or anyone close to them it must be
deflected out
projected pinned on the system
the police white supremacy
america that's where all of the
the blame and the fault and the
responsibility it sort of disperses out
like that this is a really insidious and
harmful thing
not just to the people being unjustly
faulted for the actions of others but
for the people who
aren't being faulted it's it's damaging
there too
for people who are being deprived of
agency
now you could point out that makaya
bryant was a kid in foster care she was
16.
uh she had a rough life presumably you
know she didn't have guidance
in the home she didn't have moral
formation she didn't have any of these
things that a child
needs her mother was in front of tv
cameras minutes after she was killed
i mean right away the mom was out in
front of tv cameras
uh talking about what an angel her
daughter was
but her mother apparently wasn't raising
her she wasn't in the home
with her own daughter none of this takes
all of the fault away from the person
wielding the knife
no matter how old or young they happen
to be but it does put it in a certain
context
and it does mean that you can't put all
of the blame on the kid right
but then who does get the blame
the cop the guy who showed up
to stop someone from getting stabbed to
death
no responsibility for an individual's
actions
has to rest with the individual
and those closest to them those exerting
the greatest influence over those act
their actions those who are
directly responsible for them so for a
child that means the parents
the family beyond that there's there's
even some blame a lot of times that you
could
put some of the blame on the community
in this case what was the community
around mikaya bryant doing there were
it looked like there were community
members there before the cops came did
they try to intervene
even just verbally did they
step up to preserve the lives of these
kids if you watch the um
the uh body cam footage there's what
looks to be an adult
male there i don't know who he is or how
he's related to this
um and it also looks like he's in the
process of trying to
stomp on another girl who had just who
had just been pushed over
that's what it appears i mean it doesn't
seem like this guy whoever he is
uh it doesn't seem like he's trying to
defuse a situation at all
maybe we put some responsibility with
him
in the case of adam toledo the 13 year
old shot by police after
going off with his gang friends to shoot
shoot at passing cars at 3am
we know that his dad didn't live with
him his mom didn't even report that he
was missing when he had
left the house two days before and
didn't come home
um and the the older
guys in the community he was he was
hanging out with a 21 year old guy
this 13 year old who was shooting guns
with
so that guy and the other people in his
gang rather than being good role models
that's what they're doing with him they
are inducting him into this kind of
lifestyle
so there's a lot of responsibility there
see all of it falls
on localized groups of individuals and
none of them are wearing badges
speaking of a commute of community there
was a mass shooting which you probably
didn't hear about
at a child's birthday party in louisiana
a few days ago
um six kids were shot
including a 12 year old boy dozens and
dozens of people were there
cops think that you know two groups of
of guys were feuding and that's where
the shooting started um but nobody will
talk to talk to the cops
you know like no one in um at the party
no one no one around
is talking to the cops no one will step
up for the sake of these injured kids
and make sure that justice is done the
criminals are protected
covered for the lives of the children
are not
prioritized justice is not prioritized
you know that becomes a priority only
when a cop is pulling the trigger
personal responsibility is rejected
denied
individuals not wanting to be
responsible for their own behavior
parents not wanting to be responsible
for their children communities not
wanting to be responsible for themselves
that's the theme here and it's a problem
that can be found culture-wide
country-wide you know the left has sowed
the seeds for this
the left has worked for decades to
instill in people's minds
that they're not responsible for their
own actions that their destiny is not
under their own control that all bad
things that happen to them
are somebody else's fault that they are
a victim
and only in embracing that victim
mentality can they find
freedom and power that's what the left
tells everybody
and millions of americans have taken
that to heart
that's the message that's been
destroying our civilization
you can't have a functioning
civilization of people who won't be
accountable
for their own actions for their own
choices for their own behavior
it can't work it's not working
look personal responsibility it's not
just a buzzword
it's it's a beautiful thing it's an
empowering thing
um it's it's not just what leads to
success in life
though it does you can't really have
success until you're until you take
ownership of your own
failures and faults but more than that
it leads to fulfillment
and meaning and purpose and happiness
there's no meaning in a life that you
are not responsible for
if you're just a passive participant a
spectator of your own existence
then there's no point to it there's no
joy to be found in it there's no meaning
to be discovered there's only nihilism
and despair
and we have a whole lot of that in our
culture in our cities
everywhere that's how it's going to be
until people all people
embrace the sort of frightening but
profound truth that you are a human
being you have
agency you decide what you will do
it's your decision
you have control over your own life
so take control that has to be the
message
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
the show today is brought to you by my
pillow you we we've told you all about
the my pillow pillows which are the most
comfortable pillows on the market and if
you don't believe me go get one and try
it for yourself
uh i dare you i dare you to uh to
not have a good night's rest with a with
my pillow but
if you know that you know they make
great pillows well now they're getting
into the slipper game
and you know the slippers are going to
be extremely comfortable i've
experienced them for myself
uh you've all heard me talk about the my
pillow well now they've done it again
with my
slippers the slippers took over two
years to develop and are designed to
wear indoors
and outdoors all day long the my
slippers are made with pillow foam
and impact gel to help prevent fatigue
and they're made with high quality
leather suede
i can tell you firsthand that these are
the the most comfortable
slippers you're ever going to try i am a
i maybe this will surprise you maybe it
won't i am a slipper connoisseur
and i've tried many pairs of slippers
none better than the my slippers for a
limited time my pillow is offering 40
off their new my slippers that's right
40
off i now have the sheets the pillows
the slippers from my pillows
for my pillow i like all their products
you know i'm getting everything they put
out i make sure that i get
i get it so you got to go to
mypillow.com and click on the radio
listeners square and use promo code
dailywire
you'll also get deep discounts on all my
pillow products including the giza dream
bed sheets the my pillow mattress topper
and my pillow towel sets
or call 800-951-7163 and use promo code
daily wire visit mypillow.com now
or call 800-951-7163
well i am in austin today by the way
i'll be speaking at ut austin
um giving my my talk uh delusions of
gender
how the left turns boys into girls
again you know i expect in austin
for my my own my presence and the
subject of the talk to receive a very
warm welcome we'll see
um so i'm looking forward to that you
know flying
i i just can't
the only problem i'm excited to be to be
out and
and speaking again in front of actual
crowds of living people
and i'm hoping to do more of that you
know after the whole speaking circuit
was
shut down for over a year basically but
flying has always been a challenge for
me
now even more so when you have to wear a
mask the whole time
and also it's become i don't know i i
can't explain
why it bothers me so much but it just
does when i'm sitting this happened to
me yesterday
flying out to austin pretty short flight
but
um you know i'm sitting on the aisle
seat
and it's this all this is the other
thing always happens to me um
there's no one sitting in the middle and
i'm thinking
thank god you know we lucked out we're
one of the only
all every other middle seat is filled we
get the empty middle seat this is gonna
be great i got elbow room
and then the last guy to get on the
plane there's one last straggler who
gets on because they didn't lock the
door in time and then he takes that seat
but anyway
he sits down there and um first he's got
a starbucks drink
um one of those frozen drinks with a
straw so that's strike number one
just drink a regular coffee like a man
but he's he's got his he flips the mask
up doesn't take the mask off he just
flips it up and inserts the straw
under the flipped up mask and is
slurping through the straw
and then they come through and they're
handing out snacks like little bags of
pretzels
so he opens the bags bag of pretzels
doesn't take the mask off just flips it
up
puts in a a pretzel puts the mask down
chews takes another pretzel flips the
mask up again inserts
and i'm catching this out of my
peripheral and it is driving me insane i
i don't know exactly why it annoys me so
much
but i just wanted to say it like dude
take the mask off
and enjoy your your your girly drink
take the mask off and have the pretzel
okay
what is this accomplishing you think you
get partial cover from kovit if you at
least haven't flipped up and it's still
attached to your face somehow my god
um all right number one jen saki
yesterday
addressed the mikaya bryant shooting and
her response the official white house
response this is not
off the cuff this was prepared in
advance you'll notice that she's reading
this like she does with almost all of
her answers
uh it's one of the most repugnant things
i've ever heard i
it really is at least from a white house
so let's uh let's watch that
first has the president been briefed on
16 year old mikaya bryant being shot and
killed by police in columbus ohio
yesterday it happened
moments before the show converted came
out yes
um said
yes and let me let me just say since you
gave me the opportunity
uh the killing of sixteen-year-old
michaela bryant by the columbus police
is tragic
she was a child we're thinking of her
friends and family in the communities
that are hurting and grieving her loss
we know that police violence just
proportionally impacts
black and latino people and communities
and that black women and girls like
black men and boys
experience higher rates of police
violence we also know that
there are particular vulnerabilities
that children in foster care care
like micaiah face and her death came as
you noted just as america was hopeful of
a step forward after the traumatic and
exhausting trial of derek chovin
and the verdict that was reached so our
focus is
on working to address systemic racism
and implicit implicit bias head-on and
of course to
passing laws and legislation that will
put much-needed reforms
into place at police departments around
the country has the president been
briefed on it
yes my lord i i mean
i'm not surprised or anything like that
but
systemic racism you he was saving
a girl's life and this is the president
of the united states through a
written statement from his spokeswoman
throat not throwing under the bus is not
a strong enough term here
you know he he is just he is feeding
this guy
to the mob and they know better
these peop some of the activists out
there on the street
okay many of them are absolute
morons really really stupid and they're
also indoctrinated and brainwashed and
that's the case for
again personal responsibility i'm not
taking responsibility away from them
um especially if you're you know
running out of a foot locker with a
bunch of stolen shoes the responsibility
falls on you but many of them are really
brainwashed and
and they they really do believe because
they've been told by people like jen
saki and joe biden
that uh cops are out there hunting and
killing black men and so on
um but jenn saki and
joe biden and everyone else in the white
house they
they know they watch that video they
know exactly what happened there
they absolutely know that it's a
justified shooting but they say who
cares i don't this cop
he saved someone's life i don't care now
his life is over it doesn't matter to me
it means nothing to me
he's not a human to me
never mind the fact that what why is why
is the president being briefed on
does the does the president united
states get briefed every time there's a
police shooting does he
does he does he gets an individual brief
for every police shooting
does he is that is that part of being
the president
is that a normal function of the office
i didn't think it was
but if he was briefed then uh yeah he
knows about the knife and he knows all
of that
he knows the cop was called to the scene
because someone was trying to stab
people
he gets there he sees someone with a
large knife trying to stab people oh no
i better stop her
these dirt bags are
they want to destroy civilization
that's what they want to do they want to
they we always hear from the left burn
it to the ground burn it all to the
ground
and we know they mean that in a very
literal sense when they're burning a cvs
to the ground
but they also do as they will gladly
tell you they want to burn our
civilization and our culture and country
to the ground
and rebuild it into this dystopian
grotesque
monstrosity and that's um the white
house is fully on board with that
all right the sports world is chiming in
about
all of this and of course we always want
to know what uh people in uh you know
who what they do for a living as they
talk about other they talk about
people playing games and they analyze
how those other people played those
games but um
we really want to hear them chime in on
some of these deeper social issues so
steven a smith took exception with uh
some of the things that tucker carlson
said about the chauvin verdict
and let's listen to that you just wonder
sometimes
this is the kind of things that leads to
the divisiveness that we're talking
about
because the video was there for all of
us to see
i mean you saw folks on both sides of
the aisle
talking about this police officer and
how egregious
his actions were matter of fact i think
i heard tucker carson saying that one
time
this was egregious etc etc yet last
night
he's talking about how people there's
people on the jury that probably found
him guilty because
you know they were afraid i don't have
the direct quote in front of me
but i saw it and i read it to make sure
that i had i
i saw what i read and i read what i saw
and you just wondered sometimes these
are the kind of things that make people
shake
and make people shiver because you
realize that in the face
of such obvious flagrant
evidence conspicuous evidence
there's still going to be somebody that
opens the subject to debate
when there are certain things that are
simply not debatable
we saw what derek shoving did saw it
the world saw it there were protests all
over the world because of what happened
to george floyd
and yet he goes on national television
last night yeah
and says that that's a problem i'm not
going to disrespect
him i'm just saying that's a damn
problem it's not debatable
yeah uh aria a scholar here
a philosopher and a scholar these are
the kinds of things that make people
shake and make people shiver
what why why are people shivering
because of
what taku carlson said about the derek
shelvin case i'm not sure i follow that
exactly
but his his main point to to the extent
that it could be to cyber
his main point is that um
he he believes a certain thing
about the derek shoving case and
everyone he knows believes that thing
and the media is saying a certain thing
and there are people all over the world
who who believe that thing which is that
derek shelvin is a murderer and deserves
to go
to prison which is what's going to
happen now um
unless he is successful on appeal but
he believes that and everyone he knows
and all these people believe that
and so where did you come off
disagreeing tucker carlson how could you
disagree with what
how could you disagree with what i think
and what everyone i know thinks
everybody here at espn
where espn for god's sake how could you
disagree with us
then the girl comes on at the end and
says yeah it's not debatable
just not debatable well it is in fact
debatable
you know it turns out there's it can be
debated it has been debated
there is a another
opinion a person can have
it's divisive though it's divisive to
have a differing opinion i guess it is
yeah i mean that's
the kind of the definition of something
being divided divisive when there are
different opinions
i i'm sorry stephen a smith if it makes
you shake and shiver
i'm sorry if it makes you shake and
shiver when when someone has a different
viewpoint
when someone has a different viewpoint
it makes me shake it makes me shiver i
get cold
it's confusing mommy i'm cold this
person has a different opinion
my lord okay um still in the sports
world though it gets worse meanwhile
this is from uh
daily wire lebron james has found a way
to sync to a new low
daily wire reports nba star lebron james
posted a photograph on social media on
wednesday
of the police officer who allegedly shot
and killed a 16 year old girl in
columbus ohio
writing your next hashtag accountability
um and then let's see
the the national fraternal order of
police responded to james's tweet by
writing
uh king james with his vast resources
influence
should educate himself and frankly has a
responsibility to do so on the facts
before weighing in this is disgraceful
and extremely reckless
the officer saved a young girl's life no
amount of gaslighting
will change that now lebron did go
and um i think he deleted the tweet
didn't really apologize for it
he deleted that one and then later
tweeted again
defending it and saying well i get so
upset about
uh black black people getting killed by
the cops and that's what this is all
about
we need to count accountability
that's what he keeps saying
um and yes that's what i open the show
with
i i agree accountability
be accountable for your children how
about that
you got a 16 year old girl out trying to
stab someone to death
and yes we can say stab someone to death
we can say that she was trying to kill
someone
knives kill people
of people a year in fact in this country
killed by knives believe it or not it's
a it's a really common thing
and that knife the size of that knife
that was one that
it gets you place it in the in the right
place
um on someone's body you kill them on
the spot yeah
so if your daughter's out doing that
accountability
parental accountability literally be
accountable for your children
know what they're doing be there for
them how about that
but but lebron again um this is
lebron's a very stupid person and and we
have to remember that
um but he also still knows better
he he definitely knows better
and he's in a position where this i mean
this is lebron james this is the most
famous athlete in the world
a massive massive platform
and he takes this cop who saved a girl's
life a woman's life
um and puts his puts his
picture out there says you're next
he should be brought that's that should
be criminal you should be brought up on
criminal charges for that
you're trying to get the guy killed
what what do you mean you're next what
are you even referring to
because the cop didn't commit a crime so
you can't say you're next in terms of
criminal prosecution you didn't commit a
crime what he did was perfectly legal
and justified and good it's good that he
did it
it is good when cops stop people from
stabbing other people that's a good
thing
so what do you mean by your next that
seems an
awful lot like you're trying to send a
violent mob you
from your massive platform while you're
tweeting
from your multi-million dollar mansion
seems an awful lot like you're trying to
send a violent mob after this guy
all right number three uh ibram x kendy
is uh
pretty upset with chauvin's guilty
verdict because it undercuts his talking
points and deprives him of the chance to
defend rioting and looting
um but he's not letting that stop him so
here's what interviewed by cbs here's
what he had to say
so now what chauvin is headed to jail
but is america headed to justice is
justice convicting a police officer
or is justice convicting america
when tens of millions of americans after
floyd's murder last year
took to the streets of nearly every
american town
we were convicting america since 2013
more than one thousand people have died
at the hands of police
many of them mentally ill many of them
during traffic stops
like dante wright since the chovin trial
began on march 29th
more than three people per day have been
killed by law enforcement
many of them black and latino and young
like adam toledo
it is easy to just blame individual
officers like derek shovin
but the problem is structural the
problem is historic
the problem is every single american who
sees
george floyd and brianna taylor as
dangerous
rather than the policies that led to
health disparities
under-resourced schools disproportionate
black poverty and unemployment
and few resources for all of us
suffering from drug abuse
from mental illnesses from despair
okay shut up ibram uh this guy's such a
hack
and and of course he's now in a position
who cares why the fact that we have to
care what this guy says
well uh why why would we see george
floyd
as dangerous well i don't know when he's
forcing his way into your home at
gunpoint and robbing you
as he did to uh his his female victim i
i think that's at least one person who
can see him as dangerous what do you say
ibram
these statistics that they trot out
three people per day killed by the cops
it is so
dishonest calling it misleading doesn't
even cut it
it's so dishonest because he knows
in almost all of those cases these are
straightforward
examples of the cops shooting to simply
defend themselves from someone trying to
kill them
almost every cop shooting is that that's
why you don't hear about
most of them because you have to wonder
well so it's three a day according to
him and
we hear about a lot of them still very
very select it's obviously selective
because
as we've talked about cop kills a white
person we're never going to hear about
that but
still there are a lot that um
even blm doesn't say anything about
a lot of cases of of a black person
being shot by cops that
we don't hear blm say anything about
but because in the vast majority of
cases there's there's
it is someone just shooting at the cops
and getting shot back
things like that
now of course we wouldn't put it past
blm to make a margarita even out of
someone in that situation
and as we've seen here they made it
margaret out of a person trying to stab
someone to death so
you know i wouldn't put it past them but
it does tell you something with all
these police shootings
many of them we never hear about that's
because so many of them
even blm at this point can't figure out
a way to make the cop the villain
they could only do it in broad strokes
just by by looking at statistics and
saying well this number of people are
shot by cops
but they're not going to give you any of
the details about most of those
shootings
because if they did you would you would
say oh well yeah of course that person
got shot by a cop
but ibram thinks america is so terrible
of course and
america should be convicted and america
deserves an apology
uh deserves rather uh should should
deliver an apology to black americans
and
and it's so hard to be a black person in
america and so on and so forth i guess
my question is
um america is so terrible to black
americans allegedly
you know if you're a black american
where would you rather live
than america
no matter your race if you think that
america
is a terrible place um structurally
racist
uh evil colonialist
built on stolen land genocide all these
terrible things
what there's so many other places in the
world you could live
and i know this is the point that's
brought up all the time if you don't
like america get out
but it's it is a good question it's a
good point
if you feel that way about this country
no one is forcing you to stay here
what it's a it's a good question why
haven't you gone somewhere else
is it because there's nowhere else on
earth you'd rather be
than here maybe that should tell you
something
maybe that should give you a little bit
of perspective
just a thought all right number four
kirsten henning a former virginia tech
university soccer player has filed suit
against her
ex-coach for allegedly benching her
because she wouldn't take a knee during
a pre-game reading of an atlantic coast
conference
unity pledge henning filed the federal
lawsuit against
charles chugger ater
i guess that's his uh nickname chugger
on march 3 claiming that because she
refused to kneel he benched her
subjected her to repeated verbal abuse
and forced
her off the team the lawsuit claims that
ayder's actions violated henning's first
and 14th amendment rights
hanning a junior of virginia tech was a
starter on defense during her freshman
and sophomore years before leaving the
team
the lawsuit says ader supported
proposals by the university to have its
athletes wear
black lives matter masks wristbands and
armbands but henning dissented
quote um the lawsuit says while henning
supports social justice and believes
that black lives matter
she does not support the blm
organization she disagrees with his
tactics and core tenets of its
mission statement including defunding
the police and eliminating the nuclear
family
and so she was forced off the team for
that now she's suing
um and good for her i mean good for her
on all accounts
and this is what we need in our culture
we need people who are
these quiet unheralded
acts of heroism every day by by everyday
acts
little everyday acts of heroism by
everyday people
as a politician would say um that's
that's what we need
someone people who are willing to say
you know what i'm not this
i'm i'm not going to take a knee for
this i don't believe in this
not going to do it
we all we all need to start doing that
in our private lives even when there's
a possibility of repercussions that's
where courage comes in
[Music]
if you know this
we are living in a moment in history
right now that really calls for courage
every moment calls for courage this
moment
especially does
and if we're not going to have any
courage at all then there's there's no
hope
because we know what's demanded of us
like that
i think a lot of people a lot of
rational people
sane people who aren't on board with all
the craziness
um what what they hope is that
okay i don't want to have to go along
with this
actively so i'm hoping that they'll
leave me alone and i can live my life
and have my own point of view and uh and
that's it
and they'll and you know and they can do
their thing i'm not gonna stop them but
they'll let me do my thing that's i
think that's what most
a lot of people are hoping that's that's
what they can do kind of live their life
and uh they don't have to actively
involve themselves in this stuff that
they disagree with
but they're not gonna actively protest
it either
but that's not gonna work anymore the
left
isn't going to allow that they're not
allowing that it's not no you you
can't simply live your own life and have
your own views
and let them do that was that was 20
years ago right
that 20 years ago it was uh let people
you know leave us alone and let us be
how we live how we live and have our
value systems and all of that and and um
that was 20 years ago tolerance that was
back when we were talking about
tolerance
simply tolerate it allow it don't
interfere
we are way past that
now your active approval
and not just approval but participation
is mandatory
and that's where the choice comes in
the third option of you going over here
and doing your own thing
that's gone now you have to decide
am i going to actively go along with
this thing that i don't believe in
or am i going to take a stand for what's
right i think that's that's the choice
we all
have to make all right um
it kind of it reminds me of i think i
know i've brought up before
a great passage in soldier easton's
gulag archipelago i think in volume one
uh where they're they're talking about
there's a uh
this is all about the the gulag system
the labor camp system in soviet russia
and he was talking about a there was
some sort of political
meeting rally um
and the great father stalin was was
mentioned and everyone
had to stand up in the crowd and give a
standing ovation to the great father
and the standing ovation went on you
know
one minute two minutes three minutes
four minutes and i guess usually
everybody will stand up and give a
standing ovation and then they all kind
of organically sit back down
but that didn't work that way this time
and it went on
for longer than usual and so now it's
getting conspicuous and the problem is
someone in the crowd has to has to be
the first to sit down and stop
applauding
stop participating someone has to do it
or they're going to be here all night
applauding and finally one guy after
like 10 minutes
says all right that's enough of that and
sits down and uh
and later he's the secret police come in
and they take him out of his house
and they put him in a send him to a
labor camp for 10 years
and he's told by the interrogator never
be the first to stop applauding
and that's kind of what what what we're
facing in our culture
we have we have to stop applauding
stop participating stop giving our
approval to these things
unfortunately you know whatever the
consequence is it's not going to be 10
years in the labor camp at least not yet
okay
from the new york post it says before
you buckle up
get yourself a good playlist and a
strong cup of joe a new experiment has
found a link between listening to rap
music and having strong coffee with
better driving skills
uk-based behavioral science consultancy
cx
lab and car insurance company you switch
collaborated on the experiment in which
they virtually measure
103 drivers reaction times under various
conditions
um so what were the conditions
those factors were drinking a strong cup
of coffee 20 minutes before taking the
test
listening to an audio track of noisy
children and
listening to rap techno heavy metal and
classical
heavy metal classical jazz or r b music
researchers found that caffeine had the
biggest impact leading drivers to stop
an average of 26 yards earlier than
uncaffeinated drivers after spotting a
hazard while traveling at 70 miles per
hour
music made the second most significant
difference in reaction time improvement
listening to rap music
made participants stop an average of 16
yards sooner than listening to no music
r b on the other hand was found to
worsen reaction time by about four yards
listening to noisy children while
driving made the least significant
difference improving reaction time by
about 14 yards
though it's surprising that it improved
reaction time at all okay none of this
is really surprising to me at all i mean
first of all r b
classical and jazz will put you to sleep
so of course it's going to slow reaction
times
techno and heavy metal will give you a
headache and again that's not going to
help with your reaction time
rap music could put you to sleep or give
you a headache but
it's actually more it's more like the
sound of the noisy kids
where it sort of sharpens your focus on
the road because
you're trying so hard to ignore it like
i've done some of my best driving
with four screaming kids in the back
seat because you have to mentally train
yourself
to concentrate your focus on the road a
lot of times
the lazy driving comes in or the the
inattentive when you you get lost in
thought you're thinking about this other
thing
but when you've got kids screaming you
can't really do that you can't think
about anything else and so all you're
doing is focusing on the road
that's what i it really does sharpen
your senses
but this is what really got me it says
uh last last sentence in the article
says
women were founded to generally have
faster reaction times than men
in driving now that's fascinating
because we know that women generally are
terrible drivers
no offense so at first i was surprised
by that said women have the faster
reaction times and then i realized that
no that makes sense because women will
react to things
on the road before they even happen
right so they're they're they're way
ahead of the game
like my wife for example if if we're if
we're driving
and a big like a big rigged truck comes
in the other lane it just just drives by
us in the other lane
she'll panic because she immediately
assumes that that truck is going to try
to get over into our lane
so she's reacting to that to that truck
uh merging into our lane even when it
isn't
so maybe that's it i don't know i'm
trying to figure out how the science
works here that would be my
my guess all right let's move to reading
the youtube comments this is from uh
alan snackbar says congratulations from
south africa your justice system now
also officially joins the great
tradition of the pitchfork mob
influencing the justice system
this is not a um yeah well thank you for
that
those well wishes but to me this is not
much of a celebratory moment
another comment says i'm 12 weeks
pregnant right now and hearing the
unborn referred to as
medical waste is very upsetting but
that's our society sadly
that is to the abortion industry that is
literally what
an unborn human is medical waste and
after the abortion
after the murder is completed then um
the child is is tossed out
you know in a medical waste you know
uh dumpster
if if they aren't first harvested for
parts by planned parenthood
and it is yeah upsetting very upsetting
it's the reality too um
another comment says notice that
chauvin talking about at the trial when
shoving was found guilty and taken away
says notice that chovin stood and calmly
placed his hands behind his back
where would we be if george floyd had
done the same
that is a very it's a very good point
that's the kind of point i wish i had
made
um yeah
very good point catherine says i love
how you say vice president biden and
president kamala harris
that made me chuckle it's sad but true
well yeah it's it's not even a matter of
co-president
you know um addressing the nation
yesterday after the shogun verdict
camille harris spoke first i mean
joe biden stood off the side and the
vice president spoke first
to have her there at all for these kinds
of things
is bizarre and other presidents didn't
do this
i mean barack obama when he was giving
an address to the nation he didn't bring
joe biden in to do or say anything
not only is he bringing camilla harris
in but she gets to speak first he takes
a he
plays second fiddle to her
um and finally mighty matzo says matt
just curious but do you watch
ancient aliens not a dig it's my
favorite show
thanks and have a better day tomorrow my
friend
i love ancient aliens that is a great
show
awesome show it is it's you you have to
engage with it as
science fiction which it mostly is you
never know i mean it could be that
aliens did all this and they built the
pyramids and everything else
um but
it's mostly to me really entertaining
science fiction and i i enjoy it on that
level any look i think it's obvious any
alien related thing i'm into it i love
it okay
you know we all like to complain about
well we might not like complaining i
like complaining maybe you don't but we
all do complain about
the the fact that there are very few
seems like very few companies out there
that support us as conservatives have
our same values
uh and so anytime we're buying anything
or
anytime we're in the role of a customer
it's like we're giving our money to
people who hate us and that is the case
oftentimes and that's why it's so
important when you find a company
that does support your values to support
them and that's what charity mobile is
all about
one company that fits the description of
you know a company with morals
and conservative values is charity
mobile the pro-life phone company five
percent
of your monthly plan price goes to the
pro-life pro family charity of your
choice
uh and that's you know that's that's the
great charity part of it
also it's a great service and new
activations and eligible accounts get a
free cell phone with free activations
and free shipping
there's no contract there's no
termination fees there's no risk with a
30-day guarantee so you might as well
try
charity mobile out if you're skeptical
for some reason are they you know
as good as matt saying well then get
give it a try and you're gonna you're
gonna love the service they've got live
customer service based in the usa
also you can block the use of cellular
data picture messages text messages on
any and all
of your accounts get free usage alerts
you get a free app to pay your bills
monitor your usage all of that all while
you're helping to build
that culture of life in america while
supporting a pro-life phone company
um and it's it is the win-win situation
um that we're all looking for as
customers right so call them at
1-877-474-3662 or chat with them
online at charitymobile.com and you know
if you need another reason to join the
daily wire i want to remind you
if you're not already a member you're
missing out on candace dailywire's new
talk show hosted by candace owens
and this week's episode is a major truth
bomb as candace dives right into the
derek chauvin trial verdict and gives
her breakdown on george floyd's death
plus you don't want to miss this week's
special guest dana white
president of the ufc the show streams on
fridays at 9 pm eastern
8 pm central only on dailywire.com you
can get 25
off a new membership with code candace
so make sure you go there now and get
that new membership
get the 25 off now let's get to our
daily cancellation
[Music]
today is a product of pure frustration
uh which could probably describe every
daily cancellation i could really
describe
every moment of every show i'm gonna be
canceling two of the most inane
incoherent irrelevant misleading
uh talking points that always come up
with any
high-profile police shooting um and i
you know we've mentioned these in the
past but i think i think it's time that
we really focus on them
for a moment at least these are and
they've especially
reached fever pitches in response to the
micaiah bryant incident
these are talking points that reveal a
fundamental misunderstanding of the law
of the real world you know and they are
these
number one why can't the cops
just shoot the person in the leg there's
been a lot of that
number two why did fill in the blank
black suspect get shot if dylan roof the
charleston church shooter was taken
alive
must be racism those are the two you've
seen these talking points a lot
i hear them all the time so let's take
these one at a time starting with number
one
why can't the cops shoot in the leg well
as it happens the police chief
in um columbus ohio was asked this
this very question by a member of the
media and uh
he provided the answer i think let's
listen to what he has to say
couldn't have just shot her in the leg
so she dropped could he have shot her in
the arm something like that
right you know one of the uh the
difficult things with that
is um when you're trying we we don't
train to shoot the leg
because that's a small target we train
to shoot center mass what is available
to stop that threat
there was a threat going on a deadly
force threat that was going on so the
officer is trained to
shoot center mass the largest part part
of a body
that is available to them when you try
to start shooting legs
or arms rounds miss and then they
continue on and there are people behind
that
that could be in danger that are not
committing anything
so we try and minimize any danger to
anyone else
if we have to use our firearm so i think
he successfully answers
that question and it should be enough
for anyone who was seriously confused
about it i think the answer you just
heard there is good enough but to
emphasize his point
let me add that though i am not a law
enforcement officer
i do realize one fundamental fact
we are not living in a john wick movie
okay in the real world john wick doesn't
exist
and the guy who plays him keanu reeves
is a 56 year old dude
who probably can't do 12 push-ups and
certainly can't single-handedly dispatch
um a whole room full of mob hitmen okay
that
in the real world that doesn't happen if
we lived in a movie then sure you'd
simply
if you're the cop uh you'd shoot the
knife or whatever weapon out of the
perps hand
maybe deliver a couple a couple of
karate chops or roundhouse kicks
the suspect is knocked unconscious just
for long enough to put them in cuffs
and everyone gets out alive you know
though
and and um though maybe the the badass
tough as nails cop
gets chewed out by the police captain
you know
for for showboating as always that's the
way it goes in film
and the great thing about film is that
everything is neat
and it follows a certain structure and
there's no
random misery and death there might
there might be misery and death
but it serves the purpose of the story
and everything usually works out okay in
the end
that's the way it goes in movies again
that's not reality reality is messy
cops live in messi
all day there's no script you have to
make quick decisions
and you make the decision that has the
highest probability of bringing out the
least
bringing about the least horrible
outcome
you also can't guarantee that the bullet
is always going to go where you want it
to go
if you shoot for a hand which is a small
fast moving target
you'll probably miss and you'll hit
whatever or whoever is on on the other
side of that hand and in this case
um you would have been hitting the very
person you were trying to save
if you shoot for the leg again a smaller
fast
moving target there's a good chance
you'll miss
and then that means that the dangerous
armed assailant will succeed in causing
whatever harm they were trying to cause
to whoever they were trying to cause it
to also even if you hit the person in
leg again because this isn't a movie
they aren't going to automatically go
down
right they're not going to automatically
fall to their knees and start shaking
their fists
and saying ah foiled again you know no
they'll probably still be moving and
there's there's
there's no reason why in this case in
particular she couldn't have finished
the movement i mean she had her hand
back like this with a knife in it
even if you shot her leg that's not
gonna stop her from doing this and
stabbing somebody
she could stab multiple times after
getting shot in the leg
remember in the real world all you can
do is choose the least
horrible outcome
in this case the most horrible outcome
in the
the bryant case is that the assailant
stabs an unarmed girl to death right in
front of you that is the most horrible
outcome
from the perspective of a police officer
you want to avoid that
the least horrible is that you stop the
assailant by the quickest and most high
percentage
method available shooting center mass
right in the chest
is it's not so that you'll have the
highest chance of killing them it's so
you'll have the highest chance of
stopping them from doing
what they're doing sadly that often
means killing them
that's not the point the point is to
stop them
again least horrible messy situation
i wish you didn't have to be that way
but it does all you really have to do
here to understand
why it has to be this way is put
yourself in the shoes
of of the girl who is about to get
stabbed
okay and pause the tape right there and
imagine this you're pinned against a car
someone has a butcher knife they have
their arm all the way back
winding up you know with ready to thrust
that blade into your body
if it hits you in the heart you're dead
if she gets you in the gut
you might be dead or you might live with
internal organ damage or worse
if she gets you in the face you could be
dead you could be blind you could be
hardly disfigured
you see a police officer right behind
her he has this gun out what do you want
him to do
in that situation what do you want him
to do right then and there
do you want him to choose a lease a less
effective option to prevent you from
being butchered in hopes of also
preserving the life of the person trying
to butcher you
or do you want him to just stop her
now you probably if you if you notice
this and you were you were cognizant of
it you'd probably be shooting shoot her
shoot her you want you want her to
she's about to stab you you want you
want this to be you know you don't want
to be
you don't want to give your life so that
for the sake of your assailant not being
shot when they're trying to stab you
um well you know what what would we what
would we all really want in that
situation
if we could have anything we would want
john wick to be there or or superman or
you know spider-man who can shoot his
webs
and uh you know put put it put an end to
it we'd want that
but we can't have that and uh so
then what we're gonna have is a cop in
the real world and that means
least horrible outcome they shoot that's
the first talk about the second is this
uh what about dylann roof he was taken
alive
they bought him burger king how
scandalous is that
well this one is really simple it's not
even complex and messy like the first
one was
it's really easy dylan roof did a
horrific thing and was sentenced to
death for it
he was taken alive because he
surrendered peacefully
the only way to not take him alive would
have been to execute him on the spot
while he is clearly and unambiguously
surrendering now you might say the cops
have done that before
on rare occasion like they did to daniel
shaver uh yeah and
they have on rare occasions that's bad
okay we don't want them to do that
in almost every case they don't do that
and it's good that they don't do that
if j if dylann roof had drawn up on the
cops
they would have shot him dead in a
second and nobody would care without it
without any hesitation
if dylann roof had wrestled the cops and
run away and like reached into his car
they would have shot him dead right then
and there again nobody would protest or
care
um but he didn't do any of that
and that's why he survived so that he
could be sentenced to death
almost every black and white suspect who
surrenders peacefully
makes it out alive and that's how
in the few exceptions where they
surrender peacefully and are still
killed usually the cop is prosecuted so
there's no issue here um why was dylann
roof given burger king well because
he we have to feed bad guys in custody
it's a law
starve him refuse him food and water and
that's a good way of making sure the bad
guy walks free
the beltway snipers two two black people
serial killers who terrorized the
baltimore
dc area for weeks and i remember this
well
we're taken alive and and and given food
while in custody
why because they surrendered peacefully
they didn't give the cops a reason to
shoot them
give the cops a valid reason to shoot
you and they might
so don't do that it's really not hard
it's not hard to refrain from attacking
the cops or fighting them or trying to
kill them
or trying to kill other people in front
of them that's that's not a hard thing
that's not a high bar to get over
it's not an unreasonable demand is it
it's not an infringement it's a very low
bar
don't fight the cops don't try to kill
them don't try to kill anybody in front
of the cops don't try to kill anybody
any
any time even if the cops aren't there
you know that's the most ideal scenario
um and just follow those basic rules
of life and you're not guaranteed
success and happiness but at the very
least you're probably not getting shot
by the cops
very very low bar if you can't clear
that very very
very low bar you might get shot such is
life
and such is death and that's the reality
those who don't understand it or would
deny it
are you guessed it cancelled
that will do it for us today if i see an
austin then uh tonight then great
otherwise
i'll talk to you tomorrow godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show was produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling our technical
director is austin stevens
production manager pavel vadasky the
show is edited by sasha tulmachov
our audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
makeup is done by nika geneva
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matt wall show is a
daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 21. today on the
ben shapiro show the media lie about
systemic police racism the white house
the media and lebron james target a
police officer for shooting a black
teenager who is trying to stab
another black teenager and the bite
administration cracks down on police
departments so everything is going great
that's today on the bench hero show give
it a listen